custom Moschino you look like you
genuinely look like Barbie thank you
that's the vibe we're going for 70s
Barbie okay well you achieved it
definitely another nomination tonight I
know it never gets old yeah oh no never
it's amazing I'm here with my mom again
and we're just this time we're just
having you know we're gonna enjoy
ourselves who are you looking forward to
seeing tonight oh my gosh I'm excited
for Bad Bunny ah everybody loves a Bad
Bunny moment right yeah
now I um you had said that you're
working on new music but this next album
is going to be completely different than
what we use to get from you why is that
uh it's definitely more in the 70s dance
World okay so it's something I've never
done before so I'm very excited for it
you're up tonight for dance electronic
you know so what is it about that dance
genre that grabs you I say uh as long as
people want to dance dance music will
never die
I'm loving the Farrah Fawcett Vibe I'm
getting it I'm taking it all of that
have a great time tonight baby good to
see you too yes indeed
foreign